الينا النائب الاول لوزير السياسه
الزراعيه والغذاء في اوكرانيا تراس فيسكي
مرحبا بك سيد تراس هناك مخاوف كبيره من
عدم تدفق الحبوب بشكل كافي لسد الفجوه
الغذائيه الكبيره في العالم تعلم ان هذه
الحرب دمرت مستودعات الغذاء بشكل كبير
واثارت الرعب هل هناك ضمانات لاستئناف هذا
التصدير بشكل جيد
الحبوب لاننا ندرك
اهميه اتفاق تصدير الحبوب
واهميته
التزويدي الحبوب المزروعه في اوكرانيا الى
الدول التي هي بحاجه اليها
ولهذا السبب من الضروري ليس فقط لاوكرانيا
بل للعالمي اجمع ان
يتم تمديد هذا على الاتفاق في الاسابيع
المقبله ستردنا الانباء حول مستقبل هذا
الاتفاق
نعم ولكن ارجو ان يتسع صدرك هناك اتهامات
لاوكرانيا بانها قامت بحرق الحبوب في
ميناء ماريوبل بانها قامت بتلغيم البحر
الاسود بانها عاقت التصدير بشكل ما في
مرحله ما وبالتالي هناك مخاوف من ان يتم
استخدام سلاح الغذاء كسلاح في الحرب للضغط
اوكرانيا
تبذل اقصى ما بوسعها لتصدير الحبوب وفي
الحقيقه ومنذ بدايه الحرب
اكثر من 50 مليون طن من المنتجات الزراعيه
اولها الحبوب تم تصديرها
وكان هذا خلال فتره الحرب
فهذه اشاره واضحه
عن عدم حرقنا او فعلنا اي شيء يعيقه تصدير
الحبوب نحن مستعدون لتصغير اكبر كم ممكن
وفي الحقيقه وفي الاشهر القيمه الماضيه
فان كميات الصادرات
بلغت تقريبا نفس نسبه التصدير قبل الحرب
وهذا دليل على ان اوكرانيا لا تستخدموا
الحبوب اي انواع من المواد الغذائيه
لتحقيق اي من المكاسب
وخاصه في افريقيا نتيجه نقص كميات التصدير
في ظل الاتفاقيه الجديده هل هناك ارقام
معينه يتم التعويل عليها لاستئناف التصدير
بشكل كما كان او قريب مما كان قبل الحرب
هدفنا
تحت الاتفاق الجديد هو تصدير اكبر كم ممكن
وحد نفس النسب والكميات ما قبل الحرب ويجب
ان يصدر هذه الكميات من اوكرانيا من اجل
الدعم مستوياتي الاسعار او جعلها متاحه
للعديد من الدول من ضمنها القاره
الافريقيه
فنحن نسعى لتصدير كافه الكميات المناسبه
والضروريه التي لدينا في الاتفاق الجديد
هناك اتهامات متبادله دائما بينكم وبين
روسيا انتم تحملون روسيا مسؤوليه الامن
الغذائي في العالم وهي تحملكم ايضا
مسؤوليه الاخلال بهذا الامن ولكن في
النهايه هناك من يدفع الفاتوره وهذا الامر
من وجهه نظر البعض امر غير اخلاقي ان يتم
اللجوء اليه في صراع بهذا الحجم
اوكرانيا
مستعدا للتصدير كل كمياتي على الغذاء
والحبوب باسرع وقت ونحن مستعدون
لتمديد هذا الاتفاق وتصويره من موانع
البحر الاسود الى ان الروس هم الذين منعوا
حركه
السفن في بوسفور ولهذا السبب مره اخرى نحن
نمنع اي من الشحنات
المتوفره والمسموحه من قبل الروس كلها
مستعده وجاهزه للتصدير لهذا نحن نطلب من
الشركاء الدوليين اللي ادعمنا على تحقيق
التصدير الحرمه سيزيد من الكميات ويزيد من
سرعه التصدير وسيظهر ان اوكرانيا مستعد
لتغذيه العالم النائب الاول لوزير السياسه
والزراعه والغذاء في اوكرانيا تراث
بسيوتسكي شكرا لك على هذه المقابله